STEVE: EVENING EVERYONE AND
WELCOME TO THE NEXT REVOLUTION
DYNASTY HILTON AND THIS IS THE
HOME OF POSITIVE POPULISM BIT
PRO- WORKER, PROFAMILY, PRO-
COMMUNITY.
LAST SUNDAY WE WERE REELING FROM
THE MURDERS IN EL PASO AND
DAYTON.
NOT MUCH TO BE POSITIVE ABOUT
BUT WE NEED TO TRY IT TONIGHT
THAT IS WHAT I WANT TO DO.
TO MOVE FROM HATE TO HOPE.
TO BE POSITIVE.
THAT IS WHAT THE PRESIDENT DID
THIS WEEK.
HE SET OUT THE WHITEST AND MOST
AGGRESSIVE PLAN TO FIGHT THE
EVIL OF WHITE SUPREMACY THIS
COUNTRY HAS EVER SEEN PUTTING
THE FULL RESOURCES OF THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO FIND A NEW
EFFORT TO RECRUIT OUT THIS
CORROSIVE NEW RACISM, ONLINE AND
IN COMMUNITIES.
HE'S TAKEN THE LEAD ON GUNS
PUSHING FORWARD, UNDERSTANDING
THE NATIONS THE MAN'S AND ITS
RESPECT FOR THE SECOND
AMENDMENT.
YOU'LL GET TO THAT ISSUE IN THE
MOMENT.
ON WHITE SUPREMACY, GUNS,
SUBSTANCE IN TERMS OF POSITING
POLICY ACTION LEAVING LEAVING US
FROM HATE TO HOPE AND THAT IS
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS DOING
LAST WEEK BUT WHAT WITH THE
DEMOCRATS DOING THE MAC THEY
CHOSE HATE.
HATE DIRECTED TOWARDS THE
PRESIDENT AND HIS SUPPORTERS.
THEY ARE SO INTOXICATED BY THEIR
OWN SELF RIGHTEOUSNESS AND SENSE
OF MORAL SUPERIORITY THAT I
DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW THEIR
RHETORIC HAS HURT.
WHEN THE ATTACK PRESIDENT TRUMP
HALF OF AMERICA HEARS IT AS AN
ATTACK ON THEM.
THE DEMOCRATS CALLED THE
PRESIDENT EIGHT WHITE
SUPREMACIST.
WHEN HE HAD LITERALLY JUST
ANNOUNCED AN ALL-OUT ASSAULT ON
WHITE SUPREMACY.
THEY CALLED HIM A RACIST WHEN HE
HAS PUBLISHED AN IMMIGRATION
PLAN THAT LITERALLY CALLS FOR
OVER A MILLION NEW IMMIGRANTS
EVERY YEAR AS LONG AS THEY COME
HERE LEGALLY AND ON MERIT.
BEN CARSON NAILED IT.
>> A RACIST WOULD NOT BE DOING
THE THINGS THE PRESIDENT IS
DOING WITH THE SECOND CHANCE AND
WITH OPPORTUNITY ZONES AND WITH
THE THINGS I JUST MENTIONED.
THERE ARE SO MANY THINGS A
RACIST WOULD NOT BE DOING.
I DON'T KNOW WHY PEOPLE DO IT
AND I GUESS IT'S POLITICAL BUT
IF WE COULD STOP BEING
POLITICIANS AND START THE
REPRESENTATIVES OF THE PEOPLE
AND ACTUALLY DEAL WITH THE
PROBLEMS THAT THEY HAVE I THINK
WE CAN MAKE A LOT OF PROGRESS AS
A NATION.
STEVE: I SO AGREE WITH THAT.
LOOK, WHEN I HEAR THE DEMOCRATS
SMEAR FROM SUPPORTERS THE WAY
THEY HAVE THIS WEEK EVERYTHING
IN ME WANTS TO HIT BACK.
I WON'T BECAUSE I DON'T WANT TO
RAISE THE TEMPERATURE I WANT TO
LOWER RATES.
UNLIKE THE DEMOCRATS WHO TALK
ABOUT BRINGING PEOPLE TOGETHER
BUT SPEND THEIR TIME DRIVING THE
NATION APART I WANT TO PRACTICE
WHAT I PREACH.
REMEMBER, FROM HATE TO HOPE.
HERE'S HOW YOU CAN BE POSITIVE
IN THE FACE OF THIS RECKLESS AND
OFFENSIVE PROVOCATION FOR MOST
BUT NOT ALL OF THE DEMOCRAT
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES.
DON'T RESPOND IN KIND AND DON'T
ESCALATE AND DON'T TWEET AND
DON'T POUR FUEL ON THE FIRE BUT
INSTEAD MAKE SURE YOU GET THE
ULTIMATE REVENGE WINNING.
DON'T HATE.
NOTE AND HERE IS WHAT WE WILL DO
TONIGHT.
YES, THE PRESIDENT IS LEADING
THAT DEBATE AND WE WILL DISCUSS
IT IN A MOMENT BUT WE CAN GO
WIDER AND DEEPER.
HERE'S HOW I SEE IT.
PRESIDENT TRUMP INHERITED A
BROKEN ECONOMY AND GOT IT
WORKING FOR THOSE WHO HAD BEEN
LEFT BEHIND.
WE NOW HAVE A BOOMING ECONOMY
AND WHAT WE'RE SEEING NOW IS WE
HAVE A BROKEN SOCIETY AND THAT
GIVES THE PRESIDENT HIS MISSION
FOR THE SECOND TERM.
MEND OUR BROKEN SOCIETY.
FAMILY BREAKDOWN, FAILING
SCHOOLS, INADEQUATE SKILLS, THE
PROBLEMS HAVE BEEN WITH US AND
GETTING WORSE FOR DECADES BUT WE
CAN TURN IT AROUND.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CAN TURN IT
AROUND FOR THE SAME ENERGY APPLY
TO OUR BROKEN ECONOMY.
WE WILL BRING THE HOPE WITH
POSITIVE AND PRACTICAL IDEAS.
THERE ARE HOPE FOR OUR POLITICS,
TOO.
I WAS AT THE IOWA STATE FAIR ON
FRIDAY AND IT WAS NOT JUST FUN
BUT INSPIRING.
I TALKED TO THE GOVERNOR IS
DOING A TERRIBLE JOB AND THREE
DEMOCRATIC PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATES WHO AREN'T JOINING IN
THE CHORUS OF HATE.
CANDIDATES WHO I DON'T AGREE
WITH BUT WHO CAMPAIGNS ARE
POSITIVE.
WE SHOW YOU SOME OF THOSE
CONVERSATIONS TONIGHT.
BUT FIRST, THE LATEST ON THE GUN
DEBATE.
PRESIDENT TRUMP MADE IT CLEAR HE
WANTS TO SEE SOMETHING HAPPEN
AND HE IS RIGHT.
>> I THINK A LOT OF REALLY
MEANINGFUL THINGS ON BACKGROUND
CHECKS WILL TAKE PLACE
INCLUDING RED FLAGS AND OTHER
VERY, VERY IMPORTANT ITEMS.
IN THE END, THE NRA WILL EITHER
BE THERE OR MAYBE BE MORE
NEUTRAL.
THAT WOULD BE OKAY, TOO.
STEVE: MY ADVICE TO THE
PRESIDENT ON THIS, TRUST YOUR
GUT.
YOU KNOW THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE
CRYING OUT FOR CHANGE.
THEY DON'T WANT MACHINE GUNS ON
THE STREETS AND IN THE HANDS OF
PEOPLE WHO COULD CARRY OUT SUCH
UNSPEAKABLE EVIL BUT THINK OF
THOSE BEAUTIFUL CHILDREN, THEIR
LIVES CUT SHORT, THEIR PARENTS
DESTROYED.
IF YOU ARE THE PRESIDENT THAT
FINALLY BREAKS THE LONG LONGER
JAM ON GUNS WHILE PROTECTING THE
SECOND MOMENT YOU WILL NOT JUST
GUARANTEED REELECTION TO GO DOWN
AS A HISTORIC CHANGE MAKER
PRESIDENT UP THERE WITH LINCOLN
AND REAGAN.
IGNORE THE HEARTLESS DO-NOTHING
CROWD, THAT WAS A SICK,
REPULSIVE EDITORIAL IN THE
NATIONAL REVIEW THIS WEEK.
IGNORE THEM.
THE NEVER TRUMP ESTABLISHMENT
IDEOLOGUES WERE WRONG ON
IMMIGRATION, RUN TRADE AND RUN
ON GUNS, TOO.
I SAID LAST WEEK YOUR SUPPORTERS
HATE THIS WHITE SUPREMACY FILLED